I just want to clarify something you
said in your introduction Secretary of
State you said the proportion of Corona
deaths in care homes is around the sixth
of the total I mean in week 16 which i
think is ending April the 17th care home
debts were actually 23% of the official
Cobra debts and of total deaths so not
just code word closer to a third are you
saying that the number of people who
died in care homes during this crisis is
around in line with the number of deaths
you would normally see in any other year
no one absolutely not saying that that
latter point what I was saying very
clearly is that in the statistics that
have been published so far the number of
deaths from coronavirus in care homes is
around 1/6 in total but of course the
breakdown of the statistics exactly as
you say shows that that has that's that
proportion is changing and we've got to
so I was I was putting it in the broad
context but also saying that it is an
absolute focus of ours because it's an
area which you've heighted highlighted
many times in the past and an area where
we've got a huge amount of focus thanks
Ben and Kentish from LTC can I just
follow up yes of course of course Mary
I'm so sorry no problem a lot of people
have died in care homes I've seen it
with my own eyes and you knew and your
department knew that this was a
high-risk area
you gave you've issued guidance to care
homes repeatedly over the last few
months and yet P P was inadequate tests
for the most part were few and far
between but yet the deaths in care homes
seem to take you in your department by
surprise I wonder and this hasn't meant
to be a clever catchy route question at
all but I wonder if you will take this
opportunity to apologize to those
families of loved ones who died in care
homes because the government didn't
properly protect them that's the thing
is Nick I think that's
I think that's unreasonable as a
question actually and I know you care an
awful lot about this but from the start
we know we knew that there was a very
significant challenge with care homes
not least because of the frailty of the
of the residents and and the enormous
work that's gone on within government
public health England and local
authorities and the CQC to monitor this
from the start
it has been more difficult to get data
flowing and I'm very glad we're able to
do that now on a daily basis instead of
a weekly basis as before and making sure
that care homes have the support they
need has been absolutely at front of
mind right from the start in fact I can
remember in one of the very early
discussions about coronavirus in January
the having a discussion about because
one of the first things we knew about
this virus was that it had a very strong
age profile as in it was much more
dangerous for all of the older people
that that would immediately that
immediately draw our attention to the
fact that there was a big challenge in
care homes especially because people are
more frail and therefore they're more at
risk so we it's something that we
focused on right from the start and
something that's been a huge challenge
throughout and we're constantly learning
from what happens and trying to improve
the way that we we support people across
the care sector been Kentish from LBC
secretary of state why didn't you bring
in tests earlier it just seems odd that
the it took a while for tests to come
through why didn't you if you knew the
risks and as you've just clearly said
why did it take you so long to give the
SEC that what it was crying out for and
that was tests well we have been testing
in care homes right from the start and
throughout the crisis so that's one of
the things in your question that I
dispute and I know the passion that you
have for this subject but it is really
important to base to attend to and to
express to explain what's been going on
and we've been testing right from the
start
John so
to understand that from the word go
public health England been investigating
any outbreaks of coronavirus in care
homes and the approach there would be to
test a limited number when test capacity
was limited we're talking about
beginning of April test capacity was
limited to test a number of index cases
to clarify that it was an outbreak of
corona virus the then the whole care
home would be treated as if the
symptomatic cases were all coronavirus
and and various measures are put in
place and no doubt many lives saved as a
result obviously now we have more
testing and we have more knowledge about
the way the virus spreads in care homes
were able to adapt that and will be even
more effective but it'd be wrong to say
that testing was not available and not
used and it'll also be wrong to say that
nothing was done about these these
outbreaks a great deal was done but we
are we're confident we can be more
effective now than in the past and the
the issue of care homes is an
international one every country in
Europe has had a has has had a
significant problem with a a large
proportion of the deaths from corona
virus occurring in the care home sector
we are we are no different in that
respect and the care home sector is a
highly distributed system it's very is
intrinsically difficult to deliver
services to that sector but nevertheless
a huge effort has been made in
collaboration with organizations like
the Care Quality Commission and also
local government so a lot has been done
we all want to do more and we are
certainly with testing we're going we're
going to be able to do a lot more with
this additional capacity that sector
estate described